let's go to our caller from the 954
area code who's calling today from 954
hey david lewis from miami florida i
have a similar
i guess uh situation as a gentleman from
arizona
yeah uh here in miami it's kind of like
business as usual
uh everyone's kind of treating like the
coronavirus like
a phase like a like it was springtime
a problem now it's summer and uh you
know
as i saw the news like everything's kind
of like pointing to
like almost like a second wave and i
just wanted to get your thoughts on that
like how do you
what's your outlook on on kind of the
way people are taking this because i
guess
is kind of a mix of everything yeah but
it seems like everyone's starting to go
out
um go to restaurants more you know
people are shaking hands
like the whole mess thing is like people
will
talk to who are conservatives they say
it's a hoax right
i just wanted to know like where do you
think this is going to end up two months
from now three months from now well
listen i'm glad you called because i
want to talk about miami miami is one of
my favorite places
within the united states to vacation so
let's get to miami in a second
so the the situation is there's no one
answer right now what we're seeing in
some states is very different from
others
here in massachusetts and i'm not
bragging when i say this
things really are going very well
there's some days where we only find 50
cases
and i'm glad that i'm here and not in
some of these other places now things
could turn around
we'll see if the protests had any effect
on cases
outdoor dining has opened up we'll we'll
see what happens but
we are getting dramatically different
situations in some states
versus in other states the states that
are now spiking
so you've got texas florida arizona and
some others
they may not have a second wave because
the first wave just won't end right the
idea was that by june 1st
cases would be down dramatically in the
country and they're down a little bit
but we still have 20
000 new cases a day it takes months to
decrease the number of cases
dramatically
if wave two is expected in mid-september
there probably won't even be a break
between waves one and two in some of
these states florida may be one of those
places i don't know
so in the other states that are doing
well
it's going to start to be affected by
are people
traveling in from problem states and
giving the virus to other people like if
people start coming
to florida of to massachusetts from
florida that could be
a major problem and do people in the
states that are doing better
start disregarding the rules so that's
what it's going to depend on now in
terms of miami i just got an email today
in fact
from the hotel that i stay in when i go
to miami beach
and they are offering 15 off
and you know saying we're open again and
it's all happening and it's all great
and needless to say i'm not booking any
hotel stays in miami beach right now but
it
i am getting the impression that it's
just back to normal there
yeah everything's kind of like i mean i
wouldn't say 100 normal but it's
it's weird because i feel like the
everyone's world views
it's changing yeah and i think it's
because miami is one of those cities
that
you know has a lot of people but wasn't
like a new york or anything like that so
it i guess people just kind of like
pretend like nothing's happening so
right now in miami or so are you in
miami or miami beach
i'm in miami like uh basically
miami beach is a couple miles away like
maybe okay yeah i don't know if you're
spending time more in one or the other
but
so right now people are dining indoors
with no masks and not a reduced number
of tables it's like the full number of
tables
oh no i would say it's probably like
they space it out
instead of like candles like in a
restaurant they'll put like
the hand sanitizer but it's it's
definitely like nothing's happening like
you still have to wear a mask to go in
okay but once you're seated there's no
mask i mean the ac could still flow a
certain way which i think that's how
people contracted the virus in
washington yeah the ac like
spread everything so what are you doing
are you
are you dining indoors right now or are
you avoiding it um
i mean i'm avoiding it but uh it's kind
of hard because like you know
my my sister she might go dine in and i
might interact with her so like
everyone's kind of doing their own thing
so yeah you might take
steps to prevent stuff but then they
like people around you
all the time are doing stuff i mean can
you really help it
no you can't and i mean this is why the
case numbers are what they
are it's like the spike in floor it
almost looks fake like do you see how
fast the cases are going up and it's
like could that even be real
yeah it's real it's it's crazy and my
girlfriend works for like the
florida department of law enforcement
she constantly like tells me yeah people
aren't really taking it seriously but i
see the emails like their spikes and
yeah the protests don't help either
summer time some people like to
i guess not wear a mask either because
miami gets hot it's like 89 degrees
outside right now so
man that's such a bummer i i was
actually scheduled to be in miami beach
i went
i was supposed to go march uh wait march
march 25th no uh yeah right around march
25th
i had tickets and a hotel stay booked
for miami beach
and things exploded around march you
know 10 or 12.
and obviously it didn't happen i
cancelled it and
i don't know when i will next be down
there which is really sad because i do
like it
yeah that's not true well yeah that was
just my question i guess like
uh hopefully things get better but i
think everyone's world view is
it's not helping the situation anymore i
agree i agree
all right good luck down in miami um uh
wishing everybody the best down there it
seems like a very very complicated
situation to say the least we're going
to go to a break i apologize i wasn't
able to get to everybody who called in
but i did my best and we will take calls
again